well prince harry is already in the uk
he is here
he is um in isolation on quarantine
at frogmore cottage which is of course
the couple's uk
base and he won't be seeing any family
anytime soon because he has to spend
five days
in self-isolation and he will be tested
again
for coverage so what sort of a
homecoming is it going to be for prince
harry
well a deeply emotional one i think that
much we can be sure of
i'm sure that he's desperate to see his
grandmother the queen of course
the sussexes cottage frogmore cottage is
a very short walk
from windsor castle because of kobe
prince harry simply can't see
the queen for the next five days he has
to self-isolate
but of course given what has happened
and what the queen is going through i
would imagine that she is
probably the first person he will want
to see
as soon as he's been given me all clear
prince harry it was
incredibly close to his grandfather they
you know they were soldiers they shared
a love of the military
and i think you can just tell from the
tone of harry's statement
um in which he pays such a warm tribute
to his grandfather
just how much he loved him so this is
someone who has always been a really
important part of his life
and someone who up until very recently
he was in regular touch with i mean he
told james corden how he would speak
with his grandfather on zoom
does the queen know how to use a zoom
uh yes both my grandparents this is
crazy we've seen them a few times
they've seen archie running around
but my my grandfather instead of like
pressing leave
meeting yes he just goes like all
members of the royal family
will really be missing him right now i'm
told he is of course
as you would expect very upset missing
his grandfather
but also relieved to be here in the uk
and happy to be here and and looking
forward to being reunited
with his family it's going to be an
emotional reunion
and he hasn't seen his family for over a
year now
so i think many people are thinking
there is a silver lining
in all of this that finally there will
be a family reunion
of course leaving behind his heavily
pregnant wife it isn't what he wanted
to do um my understanding is that megan
was really keen to be
here with prince harry to support him
through what is
clearly a very very difficult and and
personal time for him
but she is now in the late stages of her
pregnancy she's well into her third
trimester
she's 39 as well and you know that that
comes with certain risks attached to it
um
she doesn't want to take any risks and
for that reason and on the advice of her
position
she was told to stay behind so i think
it of course it's a difficult journey
for prince harry to make on his own
and she would have loved to have been
there to support him but they are
putting
her health the health of their unborn
baby first
and prince harry has come over to the uk
alone
prince philip requested that his coffin
was taken to saint george's chapel
in a land rover that he helped to design
and we understand that just as they
walked behind
diana's coffin at her funeral prince
charles
prince william and prince harry will
walk behind
prince philip's coffin in what is going
to be a very moving
final farewell to the duke